السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قال اعلام مجلس السياده
بالسوداني عقد بين رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حمدتي
بمشاركه القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطري
وقرر الاجتماع تكوين لجنه امنيه مشتركه من
القوات النظاميه واجهزه الدوله وحركات
الكفاح المسلح لمتابعه الاوضاع الامنيه
ووفقا لبيان صادر عن مجلس سياده اقر
الاجتماع المضيه فيما وصف بالترتيبات
المتفق عليها بشان العمليه السياسيه من
جانبها قالت مصادر قوى الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي للجزيره ان قياده
من قوى الحريه والتغيير ناقشت في اجتماعها
مع البرهان وحميتي الترتيبات الخاصه بورشه
الاصلاح العسكري وصولا الى الاتفاق
النهائي
وكان ناطق باسم الجيش قد اكد التزام
القوات المسلحه
وقيادتها بالعمليه السياسيه
وايضا تقيدها بالاتفاق الايطالي الذي يوحد
المنظومه العسكريه ويشكل حكومه مدنيه
طرح رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي مبادره لجراء
الانتخابات قال ان الهدف منها هو جمع
الاطراف وتجاوزوا حاله الركود الحاليه
وقال باتيلي ان بالامكاني وضع خارطه طريق
للانتخابات بحلول منتصف يحذر ان القادم
ودع عائله تهيئه الظروف الامنيه
للانتخابات وقال ان اجراءها يجب ان لا
يكون بيدي مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله
وحدهما
وقد رحب رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه بجهود المبعوث الاممي لوضع خارطه
طريق للانتخابات واشاد باستجابه الامم
المتحده
لطلب لرفع مستوى التنسيق والدعم المقدم في
مسار التحضيري والاستعدادي للانتخابات
من جهته قال رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله قال ان هناك اراده سياسيه قويه
لاجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
قبل نهايه العام وبقوانين انتخابيه تراعي
القوانين المنظمه للعمل السياسي والجنسيه
اضافه الى تنظيم القوات هي المسلحه
وتعهدات ملتقى جنيف
واقل المبعوث الامريكي الخاصه لليبيا انه
يحث الاطراف السياسيه الليبيه على
الاستماع الى ملاحظات مبعوث الاموي والنظر
في كيفيه ان يكون جزءا من حل يكسر الجمهور
السياسي
اكد رئيس ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه
متر من مبنى اداره مدينه وقال انه موجود
وان قوته بحاجه الى دعم ناري لحمايتها في
شمال المدينه وجنوبها
قال قائد القوات الشرقيه الاوكرانيه
انه من الضروريه كسب الوقت في بخموت
لتكبيس الاحتياطات وبدء الهجوم المضاد في
الربيع وقال ان القوات الاوكرانيه تدفع
بالقوه لمنع سيطره روسيا على ضخمه
قال القائد العام للقوات هي المسلحه
الاوكرانيين انه اكد خلال اتصال هاتفي مع
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه على
الاحتياجات هي الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا
والمتمثله في الذخيره والعتاد كما ابرز
الحاجه الى تعزيز قدرات الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني
صدق مجلس شيوخ الفرنسيه على مشروع قانون
تعديل نظام التقاعد وكانت قد خرجت مظاهرات
نقابيه في باريس وفي مدن عده احتجاجا على
مشروع قانون لتعديل نظام التقاعد
وكان الامين العام للاتحاد العمل قد دعى
الرئيس الفرنسي لاستفتاء بشان تعديل قانون
التقاعد
اشكركم على متابعه
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]